[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the vile villager the
show where we play as the meanest yes
biggest POS possible and animal crossing
new horizons Jake we have quite the
episode ahead of us don't we we do we
have a new idea for pile here bile is
going to do something very maniacal and
mischievous and he's going to torment
actual people and actual people being
the people on our staff so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna lure our friends
to the meet house with amazing turnip
prices only we don't have amazing turn
up prices what we have is a lot of
bullsh time to waste now we've got a lot
of fences right and then we have some
other obstacles at the beginning that
we're gonna leave there to make things
even more painfully slow that's right
Wow his face holy cow I got a costume I
think is gonna work well okay so here's
the best part is the shop is super close
yeah
so let's I say we go left here I can
move this stuff later maybe we'd go
around this way
maybe back down here we'll like make
sure we go by this a couple times before
yeah like this way and then back this
way yeah cleared some land here and we
go up and then we can come around like
that and let's make sure put some
pitfalls in the maze too
oh yeah I got 12 pickles if we make
these lanes really really small and
short then like we're you know
realistically we're only getting one
villager at a time one person at a time
so someone's gonna get to the end and
another person's gonna come and they're
gonna have to like try to get around
each other so they come through they get
here and they see y'all dog food and we
say eat the dog food
and another why do another these brick
walls really came and clutch I just want
them to really know what's about to
happen I think the I think the skeletons
really kind of think about how long that
animation takes right there right your
box right here I've I'll be honest I did
not expect that's pretty good right yeah
that's good I did not think this maze
was gonna be this elaborate how about
right here okay I think we're good I
think we're good okay so so what what am
i saying in slack what do you think say
I say um while prepping for vile
villager turnip prices are 513 bells or
do I do more than that do like 544 bells
or something oh here we go here we go
here we go oh my god I'm so excited it's
nice welcome Ritchie to the meat house
you see a lot of butts a lot of islands
with butts on them that's cool dang it
this might be a bit of the problem here
how many people are gonna coming that's
fine
bring them all let them all come to the
me John Luke
well in a way if they all come at once
maybe Giuliana is smart enough not to
get hit by the oh my god we are
expecting I guess right we're really
expecting only one or two Ritchie gets
two roses oh yeah bring them bring bring
bring the crutch you would look like
that
looking good Steve
he wants to play she's shot Luke just
message me I swear if the prices are we
don't even know just say that you're
fine you're not really fine but you just
can't get into it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh wait what what happened to me how Oh
now you're in Kylie left back it's only
[Laughter]
84 the vile villager this week if you
have any other ideas please leave them
in the comments below otherwise this has
been a hell of an episode thank you guys
for watching and we'll see you all
another
you
[Music]